all right michelle hey
welcome back again hello how are you
it's nice to see you
so the last time we spoke you
i was i was helping you kind of get out
of this get off of figaro street and you
were
you've done amazing things since then
yes i have i i've watched you work your
butt off now you've been early now you
have two jobs
yes i do on the verge of letting one go
is too much
with the kids but i think i like the
other one better the pregnancy thing is
more exciting
i went from dealing with the elderly now
i have a job where i'm helping them get
pregnant women off the street
trying to get them started back on their
feet um
they have different classes they have
different things they have a lot of
supportive women there a lot of
counselors
basically if you're pregnant you want to
get off the streets i wish i could give
my number because i would like for you
guys to call me and at least give
yourself a chance
um anywhere from your beginning of your
pregnancy to seven months
you guys can come in get processed
they'll help you get your money
afdc leave a link in the description
give you everything now as far as being
on drugs and stuff with it
i've seen only a few girls since i've
been there i've only been there for
about three weeks already
so it's not too much i can tell you but
it's enough
i heard you delivered a baby this
morning yes hey no um
yeah it was kind of crazy i got pictures
of my phone um
different i felt like a paramedic for
once uh
we did it at our job it was a good
delivery so
i don't know i'm getting a lot of
different sides life now that i'm not
actually participating in the streets
yeah i'm just trying to get some more
girls in you know what i mean it's a lot
of activity out there there's a lot of
kids that are locked
in well you look great and you seem much
more positive and happier than
having the first couple times i talk to
you a lot more interaction with my kids
yeah and you're with your family yeah i
went to vegas to go visit my daughter
before her birthday
she's leaving so other than that i'm
doing pretty okay
it's nice it's nice to be able to help
somebody and they actually take the ball
and run with it which is
which is the plan you're amazing you
could tell me i'm amazing but you're
amazing
if anyone can just respect the help that
you give
like you tell me limit yourself but
respect the help that i give
and do something with it let me see a
little something that way i know that
i'm not just doing what i'm doing in
vain
well i think you're a perfect example of
what what the plan
in my mind should be which is like i got
you a car i got you as you know yeah
yeah
paid for your bills blessings are taking
me up and then i took all that and
my kids was not even talking to me they
were using first name basis oh hi
michelle
now oh mom what are you doing mom are
you at work like you know the
encouragement you see my hairs are
raising i got goosebumps
but it's better for me i lost that for
almost two years
so the encouragement you've given me has
uplifted me so now i have a reason to
talk to my kids
we have fun even though we talk on the
phone mostly now
but yeah you're working all the time
you're working like seven days a week i
think
almost well six this job is better
they're giving me four but on the
weekends and stuff you're a swing
you're either overtime you're sewing you
can do whatever you like there they're
open because that's how much help they
need
and they're hiring so
they have two different so far in la
where i'm at they have two different
centers
um one is for women that's farther along
and then one is for women that are at
the beginning they do cpr
lamar's they do encourage your partners
it's funny they have gay girls too like
you know doing the rainbow
thing you know what i mean i've seen
quite a few of those come through um
there's a lot of
gay if you guys don't mind me saying
that people that are actually helping
these girls more than you see guys it's
funny
i mean it's crazy but it's funny so what
do you think i mean because you've made
such a nice transition out off the
streets
into like a normal existence with a job
and supporting your
your family with without the help of a
man right
right now yeah yeah besides you my
friend
you know and i know i get to be a
bugaboo sometimes but
i'm limiting myself like when i don't
have i just don't have
so i'm trying to take a break with
everything and it's kind of difficult
when the kids want so
i tried to go call in to work do you
guys need me
to get them from getting out of the
habit of doing that to me my daughter
just had a baby herself
and the baby's three months so my 18
year old is doing more bugging than
anyone
but she's fresh to this world so she's
expecting me to be grandma
mama babysitter you know and i'm telling
her i've got a lot to do
i almost lost my apartment again you
know what i mean this covet is crazy
they'll up and down you with your hours
they'll stop you at any given moment
they'll bring you back
then they'll overwork you it's a lot
going on and no one can even remember
that they had jobs this is where it
throws me off
i'm like where is this coming from if
you really take time out and speak to
some of these people on the streets
and you really listen to them you're
gonna be like whoa
and then they'll be like oh you know
what i've seen some people run away from
me
they're like oh my god i got just from
talking to me
it's like their mind just opens up like
they remember stuff that they
were just sitting here like what do you
think the answer is for people that are
trying to
need maybe to make a transition off of
off the streets
um into a they got to give themselves a
chance
it's too many avenues if you're on
probation and parole
they've got l.a doors project 180. um
they've got it if you're not willing to
research it you're not going nowhere
yeah at least gotta do a phone call or
walk you gotta do
something that's gonna give those two
feet a better chance to get through some
door
for you to sit down and talk to someone
if you don't have patience for it then
you don't want to live
that's just my answer i can't get any
clearer than that because
i don't know had i not been introduced
to you i think i'd have stayed in a
stupor
because there was no blessings coming
anywhere i mean not even ten dollars i
would panhandle i'd recycle i
it just was too much and then i have
seizures being in the heat so i'm like
this
so getting the car first blessing a good
card
extra blessing with air conditioning
wonderful
it just keeps my um my ailment at a
lower minimum yeah but but from the
get-go from the beginning from the very
beginning when i started helping you you
got a job i know you've never worked the
streets over again
you're working i go out to the streets
people see me there
but i'm only there to help so like when
i see guys them john's and stuff
sometimes i'll even talk to them like
dude you could earn a lot more respect
and a lot more blessings if you take
time out to listen to some of these
girls
you might have the answer to some of
their problems even if it's just one
housing so many people are riding around
with information on them they don't even
know it
and they're just holding it scared to
talk shy just going through so many
different levels
it breaks my heart and i'm pushing
myself my daughter's even gotten to the
point my
20 year old she's out there she's trying
to talk to people
i'm like baby you don't have to do that
she go if you do what i do it
and then i think the important lesson is
you seem happier as a person now i am
i have a lot less on my heart i'm sorry
elderly people i love you guys but you
guys give me
stress i mean because you're so scared
like oh my god i don't want them to
pass you know what i mean and then when
you get with the older ones you start
feeling like you're dealing with hospice
i can't sit and watch nobody pass away
that's just when i hear that bill
i have to leave it's just it's
depressing
it's sad i can't and then like
my dad's older no it's just not for me
it's just scary you know when it's all
these people are in the heat they're
locked in these
metal everything you say dad you mean
step dad my stepfather yeah yeah yeah
people i see that sorry i got nobody i
do have to differentiate
the dad and the stepdad i see in the
comments very often on my videos
somebody's talking about their dad
or their mom and they mean their stepdad
yeah my mom's fast so
my stepfather's like mom and dad all in
one
so basically that's the long and short
of it um
very proud of you thank you if you guys
can they email me on that thing do i
have my email there
uh we'll leave a link okay yeah so they
can try to
i mean if you guys are pregnant you want
help i don't care if you're not pregnant
if you're young and you want help
even if i can't get you to my the center
i'm in now if i have any information for
you guys i don't mind helping
it's just it's it's got to be done
there's too many kids out here locked in
we don't even remember we have kids some
of us
so participation comes out of balance
and i'm
i'm here you're amazing thank you thank
you michonne
love you you know